[Musik]
die gärten
willkommen zurück in meinem garten
hühnerstall und in der vorratskammer es
ist anfang an so ist und so heißt dass
man es eigentlich nur
ganz ausblenden kann
aber wie schön diese abend ermitteln
[Musik]
moment moment das geht ja gerade das hin
zu weit ich habe ja schon ewigkeiten
keine story video männer und deswegen
fangen wir gefälligst da an wo das
letzte story video aufgehört hat
[Musik]
hier seht ihr aufnahmen die sind noch
aus dem vorjahr war das letzte story
video schon so weit zurückliegt dass ich
euch seitdem gar nicht mehr gearbeitet
habe und deswegen könnt ihr in diesem
video den garten vom frühjahr bis in den
sommer hinein explodieren wie
[Musik]
ich habe mir gedacht dass ich im
frühling vor allem an leitungs videos
mit euch teilen möchte die euch
weiterhelfen zu lernen wie man was
pflanzt oder was man im frühling im
garten beachten muss wo es wirklich
schritt für schritt um die inhaltlichen
tipps im gemüsegarten geht und habe mich
nicht so richtig getraut auch mal so ein
video wie dieses hier zwischen zu
schieben wo es auch persönlicher wird
und wo ich euch ein bisschen in den
alltag mitnehmen und licht inspiration
gebe auch rauszugehen und los gärtnern
aber ich bin das ist mal wieder zeit
dafür
ich habe meinen glauben leben wieder
war irgendwie macht es oft laune den
rauszuholen und sauber zu machen und zum
allerersten mal wieder ein zu kochen mit
dem sommer nicht mag den winter
überhaupt nicht geht dann immer die
sonne
[Musik]
ich will mir gerade ganz viele videos
zum haltbarmachen für meinen onlinekurs
obst und gemüse haltbar machen und da
steht die kamera ich bin die ganze zeit
hier am schnippeln und kochen und wies
das war sehr sehr sehr viel arbeit
arbeit macht auch so spaß weil es ist
eigentlich noch keine zeit zum
haltbarmachen das heißt die tomaten die
ich jetzt hier koche für das video das
wir vor produzieren müssen sind aus dem
supermarkt beziehungs aus dem bioladen
aber mich bringen das dann würden die
stimmung jetzt fühlt sich irgendwie so
ein bisschen komisch an weil es halt
dadurch dass wir produzieren müssen
gekaufte sachen sind und nicht aus dem
garten also
ich zum beispiel auch nicht aus dem
garten kann mir einen ganzen karton voll
gewesen aber manchmal lässt es sich
nicht anders machen aber ich bin
irgendwie gerade schon so inhalt gemacht
stimmung dadurch ich habe es so bock auf
diesen sommer auf riesige ernte körbe
und darauf meine florenz kann man dieses
jahr so richtig richtig schön zu machen
[Musik]
ich bin ein bisschen hin- und
hergerissen hab ich's cool finden sei
dass ich jetzt tomaten aus dem laden
essen kann oder ob ich finde weil ich
mich dann vielleicht gar nicht mehr so
auf meine eigenen freude nicht welcher
es so so cool diese grünen tomaten nach
und nach größer werden zu sehen und dann
zu sehen wie sie langsam rote werden und
ich freue mich so arg auf die und dann
die erste tomate im jahr zu essen die
erste frische tomate ist einfach so ein
geschenk und ich habe ein bisschen angst
dass ich mir das gerade kaputt mache
wenn ich eine berliner schau
ich glaube ich mich dass ich glaube ich
möchte sie nicht essen
wir bleiben standhaft
[Musik]
da an schon jemand was sich gerade ins
land
[Musik]
mein bester freund den ihr auch schon
aus andern videos kennt hat in den
letzten monaten ganz viel in new york
und in den usa gearbeitet so dass wir
uns viel weniger gesehen haben als
normalerweise und jetzt ist er wieder in
deutschland zumindest für eine ganze
weile und das genieße ich gerade total
weil es immer wunderschönes mit ihm zeit
zu verbringen
wegen dir das fast schon so ein bisschen
therapeutisches leben fühlt sich immer
so leicht an wenn wir zusammen sind
[Musik]
an diesem werk wo wir jetzt gerade sind
entnahme garten gorilla entstanden
nachdem sie das überhaupt nicht weiß
fabi macht den garten shop.de heißt
guard nur gelacht
als er den gründen wollte da hat er sich
mit seinem besten freund einen
wertvollen namen überlegt gartenzauber
sieht der typ aus nach gehört machen
dass ein gorilla
an der stelle hier wo wir jetzt sind war
ein fabians kennengelernt ich weiß noch
dass ich von anfang an gedacht haben
immer im kopf dass ich ganz schön nervös
weil er so läuft die ganze zeit
deswegen weist immer wieder
und ich denke das war auch
die ganze halle aufzulaufen
[Musik]
mein herz achtet er nicht darauf wie
viele handys
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
fabi und ich laufen gehen einfach viel
zu faul aber
wir wollen zusammengehen und dann bleibt
das so
[Musik]
was
das nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich hatte diese getrockneter chilis ganz
unromantisch
einfach in den pappkarton
aber ich hab ich mir zum ziel gesetzt
eine vorratskammer nicht endlich mal
richtig schön zu machen weil es gibt so
ästhetische thomas kammern und haltbar
machen kann so wunderschön und
ästhetisch stelle ich mein könnt ihr
euch mal diese vista als dass nach
diesen diesen chili strauß allein
sondern vom schrank unterbau mit oder
vom regal runter hängt ist einfach so
schön und ich will jetzt endlich mal zum
ersten mal in meinem leben eine richtig
schöne vorratskammer haben und deswegen
gebe ich mir dieses jahr
[Musik]
gerade der stand in sachen vorratskammer
ich habe hier die sehr großen regale die
sind auch richtig schön tief und für die
sache nicht ganz so hübsch sind diese
schränke so dass man die dahinter ein
bisschen verstecken kann jetzt kommt ein
bisschen mehr witzige geschichte dass da
ist in ein neuer wenig seelischer
kronleuchter den habe ich gebraucht
gefunden wer ist leider wie viel enger
als ich dachte so so hoch sind die
decken hier gar nicht aber ich bin ja
auch eine kleine person das heißt ich
muss mich schon mal nicht den kopf alle
anderen schuhen
ich habe in time silbernen kronleuchter
in dieser wohnung obwohl ich
kronleuchter super schön finde aber in
der vorratskammer weil man da dann so
cool kräuter aufhängen kann und das so
schön aussieht ich habe jetzt heute erst
die ersten geerntet und hier aufgehängt
deswegen ist ja noch nicht ganz so
prächtig geschmückt aber das wird noch
und deswegen braucht meine vorratskammer
ganz dringend einen chor leichter ich
habe ich an mich linie ist
[Musik]
ich habe gerade gedacht es wäre hier
unten so zwei kisten zu haben wo man
vielleicht leere gläser rein machen kann
weil das wird bei mir richtig chaotisch
oder auch deckel von gläsern und ja
gucken wir auf diesen gebieten weil das
wird echt knapp das sieht man auch nicht
an dem chaos mit tingleff und
lehrerinnen drinnen und die sind
trotzdem griffbereit wenn es ans
einkaufen geht
[Musik]
jetzt macht es bestimmt noch viel mehr
spaß die ganzen und leser der zu essen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da werde ich würde so gern wissen was
ihr denkt wir noch irgendwelche ideen
habt also schreibt mir gerne das würde
mich freuen
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch an diese
unverschämt niedlichen könnten die bären
letzten store video ausgebreitet haben
die sind ungefähr nur drei tage so
niedlich gewesen danach haben sie sich
ziemlich schnell innovative kleine das
entwickelt und tat mal wie groß die
jetzt sind es geht so schnell und ich
denke jedes mal dass ich eigentlich in
den ersten tagen der mit denen rüffeln
heute bei dieses unfassbar niedliche
stadium ein boxmeer freilich also nichts
für unsere bedienen lassen
aber das hier ist einfach ziemlich
schwer zu toppen
[Musik]
6.000 m wurde könnten wir den pflanzen
quasi beim wachsen zuschauen
[Musik]
klocke
ich finde es so wichtig meinem sohn zu
zeigen wir unser essen herkommt und
deswegen bin ich immer ganz happy wenn
er lust hat im garten zu helfen dass man
manchmal auch ganz einfach aber es gibt
auf jeden fall auch tage da hat er
absolut gar keinen bock und das ist
natürlich auch total in ordnung aber
wenn er dabei ist dann macht alles im
garten ungefähr zehnmal so viel spaß
[Musik]
b
es geht
[Musik]
ja
g
[Musik]
beides leisten
guck mal da seht ihr das da die erste
reife tomaten
[Musik]
dollar
die horneburger entdeckt
[Musik]
ich wollte dir bringen
bist du warst in der ersten brücke
probieren kann wo warst du als halt
gemacht
berlin
es ist offiziell sommer
darin dürfen
[Musik]
ich kriege meine zehen einfach nicht
mehr sauber ich habe gerade nur ein
bisschen knoblauch geerntet und ein
bisschen das gewächshaus gegossen und
meine füße sind schon wieder so dreckig
die sind die ganzen sommer über so gut
dreckig ich zeige euch das jetzt mal ich
krieg den track einfach nicht aus den
ritzen haus ist dies einfach nicht mehr
weg ich muss den ganzen sommer über
das ist mein alter hühnerstall ich zeit
geben so selten in videos wird er
einfach komplett auseinander fällt das
ist so eine fertigbau satz den ich mal
gekauft habe und ja ich bin sehr
unzufrieden damit und deswegen habe ich
einen neuen hühnerstall
sozusagen entwickelt mit einem schreiner
zusammen also die hat ihn gebaut weil
wir nämlich aufbauanleitung machen
wollen für euch und ja ich den nachbarn
und er ist richtig richtig schön
geworden sieht aus wie ein kleiner
bauwagen und der sollte jetzt jeden
moment ankündigung ins gesicht seid ihr
auch aufgeregt
markiert hinterließen
er hat den stall gebaut beste spieler
auf der welt
man sieht auf jeden fall dass ganz viel
liebe dann eingeschickt hat suchen
seitdem der stall bei mir steht habe ich
von so ziemlich allen seiten das
feedback bekommen dass das ein zu
komplexes projekt ist und das als
weihnachtsbaum und unser ziel war ja
eigentlich eine bauanleitung für euch zu
erstellen und deswegen bin ich sehr sehr
gerne euer feedback würdet ihr auf den
ersten blick sagen dass ihr euch so ein
bauprojekt zutraut also hättet ihr
überhaupt interesse an den
bauanleitungen oder nicht also lieber
das wirklich sehr sehr helfen wenn ihr
ganz ehrliches feedback geben könntet in
den kommentaren weil ich da gerade voll
auf dem schlauch stehe und wir
gleichzeitig auch nur ganz wenig
kapazitäten haben die bauanleitung
weiterzumachen im wurzelwerk team
verleiht zwei leute gedanken sind und
wir jetzt auf einmal gar nicht wissen
wie wir das hinkriegen sollen deswegen
sag mal ob jeder überhaupt interesse
daran hätte das wäre so toll darf ich
weg von euch zu bekommen waren
[Musik]
yeah yeah
de camargo
[Musik]
wieso
thomas weber
[Musik]
held wieder da
bleiben
[Musik]
thomas weber